Transcriber: Omar Sattam Al Otaibi
المدقّق: sherif Hany
أبقراط، أبقراط هو الأب الروحي
لمدرسة الطب الحديث.
ولد في أربعمائة وثلاثين قبل الميلاد .
لماذا سمي أبقراط بالأب الروحي
لمدرسة الطب الحديث؟
لأن الطب كان متداخلًا مع علوم ومجالات
كثيرة قبل الميلاد، مثل الشعوذة والفلسفة.
حتى أتى أبقراط فقال إن الطب موضوعه
جسد الإنسان ، ويجب التعامل فقط مع الجسد.
هذا الذي نعرفه عن أبقراط ، أما الذي
لم نعرفه عن أبقراط أنه كان
أيضًا عالمًا في الجغرافيا.
بل حتى دفعه اطلاعه على علم الجغرافيا ،
لدراسة تأثير حالات الطقس في صحة الإنسان.
أتعلمون من هذا؟
يبدو أنكم سوف ترهقوني ، هذا الخوارزمي أحد
علماء المسلمين الذين نفتخر بهم.
الخوارزمي من مؤسسي علوم كثيرة
وأبرزها علم الجبر الذي مازال يدرس.
لكن هذا الذي نعرفه عن الخوارزمي  لكن الذي
لا نعرفه أنه عالم في الجغرافيا والفلك ،
هذا ابن النفيس مكتشف الدورة الدموية الصغرى
نعلم من هو منذ أن كنا صغارًا، من الممكن
أننا لا نعرف انه كان أيضًا عالمًا
في المنطق والفقه واللغة.
من شاهد هذا الفيلم؟
(العجز الكبير) “The Big Short”
يدور هذا الفيلم عن المستثمر
العبقري مايكل جيمس ،
المستثمر الذي تنبأ في عام ألفين وثمانية
بأزمة الرهن العقاري في أمريكا.
عُرف في أوساط الناس بأنه المستثمر الذكي ،
لكن أنا أقول أنه هو الطبيب مايكل جيمس ،
كان طبيب أعصاب.
الدكتور-رحمة الله عليه- غازي القصيبي
الأديب المثقف السفير الوزير،
كل هذه الأشياء كنّا نعرفها عنه ،
ولأكون صادقًا ، هو من أبرز القدوات
للسعوديين وللشباب وللأجيال القادمة.
صنع ثورة في كل المجالات التي كان فيها.
الشيء الذي لا نعرفه ربما عن الدكتور غازي
أنه أيضاً المحامي غازي القصيبي -الله يرحمه
حصل على بكالوريوس المحاماة من
كلية القانون بجامعة القاهرة.
يا الله!
من الذي أتى بهؤلاء؟!
هؤلاء منتخب أيسلندا.
هذا المنتخب شارك في ألفين وثمانية عشر في
كأس العالم ، أسموه بالمنتخب المعجزة .
لماذا؟ منتخب أول مرة يشارك في
كأس العالم وقف ندًا لميسي ورفاقه.
المنتخب الأرجنتيني صاحب التاريخ كبير .
منتخب أتى من دولة صغيرة بعدد صغير .
الشئ العجيب أنه كانت هناك ركلة جزاء
لميسي في المباراة وتصدى لها الحارس.
هذا الحارس.
يعمل مخرجًا سينمائيًا ، وستة من الفريق هم
أطباء أسنان ، والمدرب كان يعمل
في العيادة في الصباح ، وفي الليل
كان يُدَرِّب فريقًا تصدى لفريق ميسي .
السؤال الآن ، لماذا ذكرت هؤلاء؟ ما
هو الغرض؟ أولًا هؤلاء نتفق جميعًا
أنهم جمعوا بين التخصص في أكثر
من مجال ونجحوا فيهم جميعًا.
هذا صحيح.
إذًا ، ما هو الشئ المشترك بينهم؟
الشئ المشترك بينهم هو عدم الاكتفاء.
عدم الاكتفاء هو من نعم الله علينا.
عدم الاكتفاء هو الذي دفع الإنسان الحجري
الذي يسكن كهفًا يضيئه بشمعه ، أن يخرج منه
حتى وصلنا إلى هذا المكان ولا نحتاج للشموع.
عدم الاكتفاء هو الذي دفعنا للسفر
بالطائرات  بدلًا من الخيول والإبل.
عدم الاكتفاء ..لا
انتبه ، عدم الاكتفاء لا يعني عدم الرضا.
عدم الرضا إنما يكون في
المُسَلَّمات (التي لا دخل للإنسان بها)
مثل أن يولد الإنسان لأب وأم معينين ،
فهنا يكون الرضا.
أما عدم الاكتفاء فهو الطاقة التي بداخلك
التي تحثك على العمل والإنجاز .
اليوم أنا لا أخترع شيئًا جديدًا ، وإنما
أفتح لك نافذة أنت غافل عنها وأنيرها لك.
أنت غافل عن هذا الطريق ، وكلامي هذا
لصديقي الذي بمنتصف الطريق ،
في منتصف الطريق الدراسي أو الوظيفي ، كان
طموح الكثير منّا أن يكون محاسبًا ،
أو معلمًا أو مصممًا للجرافيك ،
ثم بعد أن يبدأ في هذا الطريق ،
طريق الدراسة أو العمل ، تبدأ تلك
التساؤلات وتلك المتاهة الفكرية.
فيقول : أنا كنت أحلم بالوصول لهذا الشئ ،
لكني وصلت لمرحلة من (الضجر).
هنا يكون قد وصل لمرحلة عدم الاكتفاء ، مهم
جدًا أن تعي ذلك ، وليس معناه أنك غير سعيد.
هذا معناه أن عندك اكتفاء بنسبة 70% فقط.
تحتاج إلى أن تكمل الاكتفاء
الذاتي في مكان آخر .
الاكتفاء مهم جدًا ، عقولنا
خلقها الله منظمة.
في عقولنا أحاسيس تدفعنا للمكان
الذي نشعر فيه بالتطور.
الحزن إحساس داخلي ، وكذلك العاطفة ، يجب
أن نكون صادقين مع تلك العواطف ، ونوجهها.
تَخيَّل أني قلت لك أنك ستعيش
في قصر على البحر ،
في ذلك القصر كل الملذات من مأكل ومشرب
وغيرهما ، لكن هناك شرط واحد ،
وهو ألّا تخرج من القصر ، أو لك خيار آخر ،
وهو أن تعيش مع الناس وتخوض تجارب
كثيرة وجديدة وتستمع بذلك.
ماذا سيقول أكثركم؟
الخيار الثاني .
الخيار الثاني ، هذا طبيعي.
إذًا هنا مفهوم مهم ،
حريتنا وحرية اختياراتنا.
شعوري بأنني غير مقيد في مكان واحد ،
هو أهم للإنسان من جميع الأهواء والشهوات.
هذا المفهوم مهم جدًا.
وهو من الأشياء المريحة جدًا أن يعلم
الإنسان أنه حر في اختياراته وفي تنقله ،
أستطيعُ أن أذهب من مكان إلى آخر
أستطيع الاتجاه من مكان إلى آخر.
هنا ستكون سعيدًا وراض عن نفسك.
من أبرز أدوات النجاح..
هذا موضوع عام يتحدث فيه كل الناس ، تجد
ذلك في كتب تطوير الذات و غيرها.
لكن هناك أشياء أنا أؤمن بها صراحةً ،
أول شئ هو ثقتك بنفسك.
لو سألتك ونحن جلوس لا نفعل شئ :
هل أنت واثق من نفسك؟ ستقول : نعم.
ثقتك بنفسك تظهر عندما تبدأ في طريق جديد ،
وتتكالب عليك المصاعب ، كنقد الناس وكلامهم
كلام من جميع الجهات .
حتى تجد نفسك في القاع ،
هناك اسمع صوتك الداخلي ، ثق في نفسك ،
في هذه اللحظة هذا ما سيخرجك من القاع ،
هنالك ثق في نفسك وانهض ، لكن لا
تقل و أنت جالس : أنا واثق من نفسي ،
فكلنا واثقون  حتى يأتي الامتحان.
الشيء الثاني .
يجب أن تكون مرنًا في ترتيب أولوياتك ،
دائمًا أقول : اكتب خطتك بالقلم الرصاص ،
لا تكتبها بالقلم الحبر.
اكتبها بالقلم الرصاص في كل مرحلة .
لا بد أن تكون واعيًا بالأشياء المحيطة بك ،
لذلك ، لا تكتب بالقلم الحبر.
اكتب بالقلم الرصاص ، حتى تمسح وتُعَدِّل
في خطتك تبعًا للظروف المحيطة بك.
غَيِّر أولوياتك واضبطها.
ومن أهم أسباب الناجحين أيضًا
فهمهم لعواطفهم ولذواتهم.
إذا كنت إنسانًا قادرًا على فهم
نفسك وعواطفك ومشاعرك ،
ستكون إنسانًا ناجحًا في كل
مجالات حياتك العملية.
إذًا ، سؤالي لصديقي الذي في منتصف الطريق ،
أو صديقتي التي بمنتصف الطريق.
هل أنتم قادرون على أن تجمعوا أكثر
من تخصص ؟ ولما لا ، بالطبع قادرون.
اليوم والله الحمد ،
بفضل من الله  ،
أنا أتشرف أن أكون طبيبًا منذ عشرة سنين في
خدمة المرضى ، وهذا الشيء مشرف جدًا لي.
بدأنا من يوتيوب، الآن وصلنا الى أكبر منصة
عالمية (نتفليكس) وأكبر منصات الشرق الأوسط
كأعمال درامية ، وقَدَّمنا برامج إم بي سي .
وأفتخر أيضًا أننا قدمنا منتج جديد نال
الإعجاب في عالم المطاعم بالشراكة مع والدتي
-الله يحفظها- في عالم المطاعم .
في الأخير ،
هذا كلام للأمانة من القلب للقلب ،
هذا إيماني وهذه معتقداتي وهذه
التجربة  التي أحب أن أشاركها معكم.